i'm so confused like are you breaking up
with me are you not breaking up with me
oh look he's he's crying he's crying
don't none of you look at them tears and
think that's just funny
thank you for coming
first order of business i'm sure y'all
heard the twigs got pulled out the river
this morning ain't no secret he and
carvel
were up in the hood together
listen up
carville about to say some words
[Music]
okay you know what don't none of you
look at them tears and think that it's
funny
because it takes a big
man to cry in front of his crew
go ahead come here
y'all know twigs with my boy
back in the day
we used to pretend the sofa cushions was
a fort
mm-hmm
and we used to pretend that the floor
was molten lava
okay you know what though
ain't nothing funny about that
of course this man is crying
because he and twigs was kids together
okay
you know there's best friends for heaven
go ahead carvel
we used to play care bear
twigs and i would spend
the good part of an afternoon trying to
figure out which
camera we
would just start laughing cause y'all
know you think this is funny
carmel over here blubbering and talking
about care bears
but you know what
but shoot
those are manly tears
okay
there's some manly ass tears right there
that you looking at
go ahead carmel
i'm sorry man that was a weird ass
sneeze i just did right there god damn
it can the brother get some claritin up
in here
go ahead carmel
twigs always fancied himself share bear
i always
i always thought
thought of myself
as more of a fun shine there
okay
okay oh you need to respect that right
there okay
y'all need to listen to fun
i'm sorry i'm sorry man
you were funshine bear man i'm sorry
that
that is so funny
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right let's go sell some crack
let me roll
which one you want
give me both of them man okay
i decide which one i want when i want to
eat it
maybe you uh you want some of these
vegetables too
no
no
just saying man
the nutrients is good
for maintaining energy levels so
i know what the vegetable is man don't
don't tell me what a vegetable is man
i'm hey
i'm a grown ass man
all right mm-hmm
yeah i'm sorry
this three bean salad is the bomb no oh
snack
they got three bean salad up in there
mm-hmm i ain't even see that
you want some of mine
yeah okay
open the hangar
what you doing
nah you don't do that
you don't feed me like a kid man
i'm a grown ass man
okay y'all see why you got some schmutz
right here hey hey hey
on my face
you never touch a grown man's face yup
that's right i'm sorry okay
you all are grown ass hey hey
i don't need you to pat my back i'm a
grown ass man what you doing
i know you're going i don't want to hear
it anymore about grown-ass man uh that's
what i am i don't want to hear you are
you
treating me you're clean
this is the place for this country don't
start acting up here because you're
making me angry um okay then i need you
to breathe a little bit can you breathe
[Music]
are you not a baby
[Music]
[ __ ]
oh oh i'm sorry i'm sorry you're a
grown-ass man you're a grown-ass man
who's a grown-ass man you're a grown-ass
man
you're a grown ass man right
you know what grown ass man do you go to
the bathroom and change your pants with
john tp right yeah yeah okay let's go
excuse me everybody
um
i'm sorry but my son got that benjamin
buttons disease
oh
he's four well four injury gordon
i saw in the news today
talking about the violence in foreign
countries
talking about all the savagery up in the
world
but they
never talk about south central
and never talk about what happened to my
brother
now he's gone
now i ain't got no brother
[Music]
yo dog
i'll be your brother
really absolutely dark
you're gonna need somebody to lean on
you can't just be walking around here
with this emptiness in your heart man an
emptiness that can only
be filled
by a brother
okay
brothers man
brother
come over here you gotta get it in there
brothers man come here man why don't you
keep following me around man why don't
you go home and stay out of my room
nobody don't mess with my models i'm
about to get a wedgie up and that's my
[ __ ] right here
hey hey gotta get the [ __ ] off me man
hey
you don't give a grown man a wedgie
[ __ ] i'm 34 years old
i got grandchildren
so what do you want to do tonight like i
was thinking maybe we could meet up with
amy and brad and like before that we
could go to angelo's and before that we
could like just go
vegan
i have something to say
had to say it in person
because it's
it's like super important
okay
um
i know this is sudden but like i've been
thinking about this for a while
[Music]
and i know this is something that needs
to happen
i'm breaking up with you
cool love it totally fine with that
really yeah
cause i thought
i was was really worried that you were
gonna be like mad
matt
oh my god are you kidding me
no
of course i'm not mad people grow apart
it happens it's like part of life no i'm
totally fine like love it love it love
it
um
so
uh
um you know we we had a good run
[Music]
don't be a stranger
can i just
can i ask why
why
yeah like whatever's like i'm doing some
work on myself and like trying to grow
as a person so i really like appreciate
to know why
yeah um
okay yeah that's like
you know i think that you're kind of
like a controlling
person thank you
thank you for that that's nice thank you
for that
cool no problem yeah
so you know what your problem is andre
what
you keep tabs on people
every little thing somebody does you
have to keep a tab of it
wait i i
i can't tell if you're angry or not i'm
not i'm totally not angry
oh no i'm excited it's good it's just
like you said your piece
and i just think that i deserve the
human decency to say my peace right
right is that
is that not okay no no no it's
nope of course of course
you're a controlling manipulative person
everyone says it really i i don't think
that i am yes you are andre yes
[Music]
i'm not angry i'm fine i love it i love
that you came to my house and you broke
up with me in my space and then when i
think about that every time i'm here
that's great that is so perfect for me
it's the best thing around here
where else was i supposed to do it
because you won't come to my house oh
here he is the puppet master is back but
i'm not i'm not no i'm not the puppeteer
you're doing this to me it's true you
won't come to my house so my apartment
looks like two rats just in it every day
oh right like thank you for that i'm a
[ __ ] thank you i didn't know i didn't
say [ __ ] i didn't always say isn't it
am i evil or am i a [ __ ] no no you're
not evil vegan why are you punishing me
i'm not punishing you i know you broke
up with me and i'm not supposed to feel
punished i see who thinks like that
i don't know i can't i'm sorry i'm sorry
okay me again i i guess i didn't think
it through well it's like too late now i
mean we're dying no it's not too late
megan megan seriously i just i i i i had
a feeling
that i thought was true and clearly
clearly it wasn't true
i'm so confused like are you breaking up
with me are you not bringing up with me
megan i'm not breaking up with you okay
cool so what do you want to do tonight
like i want to hang out with amy and
brad but maybe before that we can go to
angelos
[Music]
what just happened
[Music]
look at this mess
makes me sick there's no way to stop
this kind of insane violence
seems like no matter what we do some
innocent fool is always going to get
slaughtered and we're always going to be
playing catch-up
we're never going to find the guy that
did this
tell that to his widow
and we're always going to be playing
catch-up we're never going to find the
guy that did this
go go look at that
that's amazing how good is this amazing
i know look at your points oh
dude you have absolutely mastered this
game yeah well since um
sheila left i've been spending a lot of
time
playing the game you're doing really
good thank you
that's why we're here man
help you get over
her
and check out this awesome new game you
have yay
you know i left something in another
room um excuse me everyone
[Music]
oh he still has the sensors on
i was like him in his room yeah you can
see him that's funny what is he doing
is he is he on his knees does he drop to
his knee oh
no no no no no he's probably looking for
him no look he's he's crying he's crying
oh no he's just
you know he's shattering he's shuttering
is he fetal yeah he curled up look at
that he's fetal hey craig buddy
you all right up there oh yeah bob uh um
i'm coming right out
[Music]
oh here uh
hey
man you all right yes yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah it's just my sinuses are acting up
yeah
yeah i um i was just you know i was just
thinking about sheila and you know what
i am i am totally over her awesome
awesome let's hey
let's get this party started sure yeah
oh
uh
i forgot to get rid of this picture of
sheila excuse me hey maybe leave the
sensor so one of us can play
oh he's dancing he's dancing with a
photo
is he he's doing he's doing this about
is he kissing it guys we don't i think
he's kissing it you know what i'm going
to turn this off because we don't need
to change it and you die
he's under his buckle look at this his
pants are coming off his pants are
coming off oh god
yeah no no no no no no no no okay that's
happened oh no no no oh gosh is he he's
he is totally on the bed he's totally
flat on the bed oh maybe he's shaking a
can of hairspray oh gosh
we shouldn't be
okay you know
is he reaching down for his foot i know
he that's his foot isn't it
i am sorry everybody
would you like me to make some snacks
wash your hands first
[Music]